>>> WE'RE BACK WITH OUR WORLD
LEAD.
A DISTRESSING STORY OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN SHOWING THE HARSH
REALITY OF THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS ENGULFING THE COUNTRY,
ESPECIALLY POST-TALIBAN RULE.
DESPERATE FAMILIES SO
IMPOVERISHED THEY TELL CNN THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO SELL THEIR
YOUNG DAUGHTERS INTO SOME
TWISTED FORM OF MARRIAGE IN THIS
EXCLUSIVE REPORT CNN WITNESSES
THE TRAGIC FATE FACING THESE
HELPLESS LITTLE GIRLS IN THIS
CULTURE WHERE GIRLS AND WOMEN
ARE TOO OFTEN TREATED
HORRIFICALLY.
THE PARENTS GAVE US FULL ACCESS
AND PERMISSION TO TALK TO THE
CHILDREN AND SHOW THEIR FACES
BECAUSE THEY SAY THEY CANNOT
CHANGE THE PRACTICE THEMSELVES.
CNN'S ANNA COREN REPORTS.
>> Reporter: IN THIS DESOLATE
LANDSCAPE, NOT A SCRAP OF
VEGETATION IN SIGHT.
A MAKESHIFT CAMP FOR THE
INTERNALLY DISPLACED.
AMONG ITS RESIDENTS, 9-YEAR-OLD
PAWANA.
HER BRIGHT PINK DRESS, SQUEALS
OF LAUGHTER AND CHILDHOOD GAMES.
A RUSE TO THE HORRORS UNFOLDING
IN THIS INHOSPITABLE
ENVIRONMENT.
HER FAMILY MOVED TO THIS CAMP
FOUR YEARS AGO AFTER HER FATHER
LOST HIS JOB.
HUMANITARIAN AID AND MENIAL WORK
EARNING $3 A DAY PROVIDING THE
BASIC STAPLES TO SURVIVE.
BUT SINCE THE TALIBAN TAKEOVER,
2 1/2 MONTHS AGO, ANY MONEY OR
ASSISTANCE HAS DRIED UP.
AND WITH EIGHT MOUTHS TO FEED,
HER FATHER IS NOW DOING THE
UNTHINKABLE.
I HAVE NO WORK, NO MONEY, NO
FOOD.
I HAVE TO SELL MY DAUGHTER, HE
SAYS.
I HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE.
PAWANA WHO DREAMS OF GOING TO
SCHOOL AND BECOMING A TEACH,
APPLIES MAKEUP.
A FAVORITE PASTIME FOR LITTLE
GIRLS.
BUT SHE KNOWS SHE'S PREPARING
FOR WHAT AWAITS HER.
MY FATHER HAS SOLD ME BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE BREAD, RICE AND
FLOWER.
HE'S SOLD ME TO AN OLD MAN.
THE WHITE BEARDED MAN WHO CLAIMS
HE'S 55 YEARS OLD COMES TO
COLLECT HER.
HE'S BOUGHT HER FOR 200,000
AFGHANIS, JUST OVER 200,000 U.S.
DOLLARS.
COVERED UP, PARWANA WHIPPERS AS
HER MOTHER HOLDS HER.
THIS IS YOUR BRIDE.
PLEASE TAKE OF HER.
OF COURSE, I WILL TAKE CARE OF
HER, REPLIES THE MAN.
HIS LARGE HANDS GRAB HER SMALL
FRAME.
PARWANA TRIES TO PULL AWAY.
AS HE CARRIES HER ONLY BAG OF
BELONGSINGS SHE AGAIN RESISTS.
DIGGING HER HEELS INTO THE DIRT,
BUT IT'S FUTILE.
THE FATE OF THIS SMALL HELPLESS
CHILD HAS BEEN SEALED.
CHILD MARRIAGE IS NOTHING NEW IN
POOR, RURAL PARTS OF
AFGHANISTAN, BUT HUMAN RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS ARE REPORTING
INCREASING CASES BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC AND HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
ENGULFING THE COUNTRY.
>> THESE ARE DEVASTATING
DECISIONS THAT NO PARENT SHOULD
EVER HAVE TO MAKE AND IT REALLY
SPEAKS TO WHAT AN EXTRAORDINARY
BREAKDOWN IS HAPPENING IN
AFGHANISTAN RIGHT NOW.
>> FOR MONTHS, THE U.N. HAS BEEN
WARNING OF A CATASTROPHE AS
AFGHANISTAN, A WAR-RAVAGED AID
DEPENDENT COUNTRY DESCENDS INTO
A BRUTAL WINTER.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN CENTRAL
BANK ASSETS WERE FROZEN AFTER
THE TALIBAN SWEPT TO POWER IN
AUGUST.
BANKS ARE RUNNING OUT OF MONEY.
WAGES HAVEN'T BEEN PAID FOR
MONTHS WHILE FOOD PRICES SOAR.
ACCORDING TO THE U.N., MORE THAN
HALF THE POPULATION DOESN'T KNOW
WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL IS COMING
FROM AND MORE THAN 3 MILLION
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF 5 FACE
ACUTE MALNUTRITION IN THE COMING
MONTHS.
>> PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN NEED A
LIFELINE.
>> Reporter: AND WHILE A BILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN PLEDGED BY U.N.
DONORS TO HELP THE AFGHAN
PEOPLE, LESS THAN HALF THOSE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN RECEIVED AS THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY HOLDS
OFF RECOGNIZING THE TALIBAN
GOVERNMENT.
>> PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN WILL BE
DYING OF HUNGER IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
AND NOT JUST A FEW.
THIS IS JUST MAKING PEOPLE MORE
AND MORE VULNERABLE.
AND WE CANNOT ACCEPT THAT.
>> Reporter: SENTIMENTS SHARED
BY THE TALIBAN.
>> WE ARE ASKING AID AGENCIES TO
COME BACK TO AFGHANISTAN AND
HELP THESE POOR PEOPLE.
OTHERWISE THE CRISIS WILL
WORSEN.
>> FOR THIS FAMILY IN A
NEIGHBORING PROVINCE, THEY ARE
TRYING TO SELL TWO DAUGHTERS.
A 9-YEAR-OLD AND 4-YEAR-OLD FOR
A THOUSAND U.S. DOLLARS EACH.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHY THEY ARE
SELLING YOU, THE JOURNALIST ASKS
HER?
BECAUSE WE ARE A POOR FAMILY AND
DON'T HAVE ANY FOOD TO EAT, SHE
SAYS.
ARE YOU SCARED, HE ASKS.
>> YES, I AM.
>> ANOTHER FAMILY IN THE
PROVINCE BORROWED MONEY FROM
THEIR 70-YEAR-OLD NEIGHBOR.
NOW HE'S DEMANDING IT BACK, BUT
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO GIVE EXCEPT
THEIR 10-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER.
>> MY DAUGHTER DOESN'T WANT TO
GO AND IS CRYING ALL THE TIME.
I AM SO ASHAMED, HE SAYS.
TERRIFIED, SHE THREATENS TO TAKE
HER LIFE.
IF THEY PUSH ME TO MARRY THE OLD
MAN, I WILL KILL MYSELF.
I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE MY
PARENTS.
DAYS LATER, SHE DISCOVERS THE
SALE HAS BEEN FINALIZED.
ANOTHER AFGHAN CHILD SOLD INTO A
LIFE OF MISERY.
JAKE, IT IS GUT-WRENCHING
KNOWING WHAT THESE YOUNG GIRLS
WILL BE SUBJECTED TO.
JUST AN UPDATE ON YOUNG -- THE
LAST GIRL IN OUR STORY THERE.
SHE WILL BE HANDED OVER TO THE
70-YEAR-OLD MAN IN THE COMING
DAYS.
IT'S JUST A TRAGIC FATE THAT
AWAITS THIS YOUNG GIRL.
NOW IF THE AID SITUATION IS NOT
ADDRESSED URGENTLY, THE U.N.
PREDICTS THAT BY THE MIDDLE OF
NEXT YEAR, 97% OF AFGHANS WILL
BE LIVING BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE, NOT -- MEANING THAT HUNGER
AND STARVATION WILL BE FACING
THESE PEOPLE ALONE, BUT THAT
OTHER GIRLS WILL END UP LIKE
MAGAL AND PARWANA.
>> SUCH A HORRIBLE STORY.
IT'S TOUGH TO WATCH.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS HAPPENED --
THESE TRADITIONS, AWFUL THING
WAS PREDATED THE TALIBAN TAKING
OVER, AGAIN, BUT HOW HAS THE
TALIBAN TAKEOVER IN AFGHANISTAN
EARLIER THIS YEAR MADE IT WORSE.
HOW HAS IT EXACERBATED THIS
PROBLEM OF FAMILIES SELLING
THEIR DAUGHTERS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
FOREVER.
HOWEVER, FROM THE LOCAL
JOURNALISTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
SPEAKING TO AND WORKING WITH,
THEY SAY THAT ONCE UPON A TIME
IT WAS BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
NOW IT IS OUT IN THE OPEN.
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY IS
OBVIOUSLY REFUSING TO RECOGNIZE
THE TALIBAN AS AN OFFICIAL
GOVERNMENT AND AS A RESULT THEY
ARE FREEZING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN RESERVES THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
GO TO THE PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN.
THEY ARE DOING THIS TO TRY AND
HOLD THE TALIBAN TO ACCOUNT,
ESPECIALLY ON THEIR RECORD
REGARDING HUMAN RIGHTS, WOMEN
AND OF YOUNG GURLS.
BUT BY PUNISHING THE TALIBAN IT
MEANS THAT THAT MONEY IS NOT
GETTING TO AFGHANS MOST
VULNERABLE WHICH, OBVIOUSLY,
INCLUDES THE GIRLS IN